oh
look who it is welcome to
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard hey
hello hey hello
hey wow welcome um so much to talk about
we got a ton there was a point this week
where i texted mark and said is there
even a point to doing the show
no news and then the news cycle was like
holding my beer and announced
everything so we've got so much to cover
on fat man beyond this evening but first
and foremost
heads up 48 hours into a fast i'm
feeling real
[ __ ] feisty
all i want to do i was just pulling into
the alleyway here i saw a [ __ ] sign
i see every time i pull into this alley
i never think about it
but today it caught my eye pizza
and suddenly i was like [ __ ] the general
public [ __ ] anybody watching this show
i'm going to that pizza sign and i'm
going to eat that [ __ ] pizza but i
didn't do it so i'm
you forget how much food structures your
day
i don't i eat three times a day man
smart man i am no hours into a fast i'm
trying
almost at a top fuji page that phase
which of course
72 hours in that kind of kicks in uh
but uh you know it's day one is always
like i fast
i enter for those who are like what the
[ __ ] going on i'm religious all right
get off my [ __ ] religious dick no
i don't i don't fast for any religious
reasons spiritual reasons
uh well maybe spiritual i fast for
self-discipline whenever i feel like i
[ __ ] go overboard
uh in indulgence and eating or something
like that i try to
tame myself back into a sense of
discipline and the fast
the intermittent fast um i already fast
on a 20-4
cycle so i have a four-hour eating
window of every day
but the intermittent fat and in that
four hours the problem is i will [ __ ]
feed for four hours
so i'm like and we start now and i'll
sit there and watch like [ __ ]
lovecraft country and eat through the
entire thing
you know just it make like something
that good is made better by like falafel
chips you know and [ __ ] like that
so uh periodically i [ __ ] reset
and and prove that i can discipline
myself so the first 24 hours
and it's not even the first 24 hours the
the last six hours of the first 24
hours are the hardest because suddenly
you're like what are you doing
like you know the [ __ ] instincts kick
in but
we're not you know as human beings we're
not supposed to eat as much as we do eat
particularly three meals a day [ __ ]
seven days a week we're feaster
famine [ __ ] creatures who only in the
last you know 100 years figured out
breakfast lunch
and dinner and stuff so the body can
fast i don't want to trigger anybody but
you know this is a thing
so uh i'm i'm right now in that
place and i made it through the first 24
hours so you wake up in the morning like
i woke up
i guess it was this morning and i was
like all right i [ __ ] i am the master
of this [ __ ]
not me like it's not gonna tell me to go
eat and sh i could [ __ ]
put [ __ ] in the way of eating well my
body eats itself
only recommend it if you have like fat
to burn
uh you know if you're a thin person
don't [ __ ] do this and [ __ ]
um but also if you're a thin person you
can do this it's actually good for your
system to do it like periodically
so um i'm pat made it past day one
but you know about two hours ago i was
like
that's why i was like can we start the
show at six because i knew at six
o'clock i was gonna start being like you
should
[ __ ] eat man so much so that by the
time i pulled up here
a little past seven i saw the pizza sign
and i was like ah
oh shoot a [ __ ] for us oh you're
not kidding man but um
but here's the thing i'm not hungry
like if if it was all about hunger you
know
[ __ ] you couldn't get between me and the
food this is about instinct
this is about habit this is about
entertainment like when i was home
eating would have really entertained the
[ __ ] out of me and structured
my day i would have plopped in front of
the tv and if i had broken down i'd say
five or six o'clock tonight
i probably wouldn't have rolled up here
i would have texted you at [ __ ] 6 45
and been like let's do this tomorrow
because i would have been food drunk and
[ __ ] like that so
you know i'm i'm right now i'm in a
almost at what time is it
it is now 7 32. yeah i have 48 hours of
a [ __ ] fast and i'm not hungry at all
i'm not like oh
god but i'm just you know bitter because
i like eating like the physical act of
eating feels pleasurable i'm a 50 year
old man
and don't get me wrong i'm i i love sex
but i like eating more
and we have this big empty house man my
kid went to dallas
to start shooting her a tv show she's on
for on freeform called cruel summer
and uh gail and byron jen's parents who
live with us
they took the kids to dallas both harley
and austin her boyfriend went
so the house is [ __ ] empty and ripe
for [ __ ]
and ripe for eating because nobody's
there to steal the rest of the food
you're not
sitting there jockeying for like oh man
harley took all the [ __ ] bread and
[ __ ] like that
because it's vegan it's just us alone in
the house
and alone with all the food and nine and
a half weeks has not broken out [ __ ] no
cause i'd rather eat
why ruin [ __ ] eating with [ __ ]
that's work never understood that scene
when i was a kid i remember seeing that
when i was like 16. i'm like
separate you got to keep them separated
man don't george costanza this [ __ ]
or you eat a sandwich while you're
[ __ ]
you gotta keep them separated in any
event
that's [ __ ] no i'm just throwing that
out there in case i seem a little
salty this week i would like to believe
me i'm
so salty i'm like give me some of that
[ __ ] bud
seltzer but that would defeat the
purpose because there are 100 calories
you can't i would be
out of ketosis and [ __ ] yeah then double
bitter
because you're drunk and bitter yeah and
going like why did i and then sad
probably crying
oh we would do the entire emotional
science absolutely
then i'd be bargaining with my body
maybe i could throw it up and then i
won't have it in me
and then eventually acceptance where i'm
like oh well i'm drunk
the five stages of bud light cells
[Laughter]
so tonight it's all salty angry
drunk bitter regretful i'm god i gotta
i gotta get control of my eating because
by the end of the month
i'm going we open movies again yeah you
do the movies pop-up is now
up for uh reservations open for
reservations at moviespopup.com
for us coming to chicago movies is
coming to chicago right in the loop
at st lou's assembly uh and then me and
jay are doing jay and salam bob get old
at the mchenry outdoor theater so
october 30th
to november 6 as the movies pop up i'm
going to be there with j grand opening
day october 30th we're going to be there
on halloween because we're there anyway
what the [ __ ]
and then november 1st we do get old then
i come home and me and mark are going to
do
an election special yeah on november 2nd
not the third right we're gonna do the
monday yeah because we're gonna
encourage everybody to go [ __ ] vote
not do it
while people should be voting and being
like stay home and watch our show
that'd be ridiculous so we're gonna do
it on that [ __ ] monday and stuff so
i know when i go to chicago
i'm going to be eating the [ __ ] out of
some free movies free
movies are you going to bring your tater
tot gun oh [ __ ] right into my mouth
spread my cheeks go right up there as
well because i don't know if you know
this or not but [ __ ] you take [ __ ]
anally gets in your system quicker kids
do that in high school they
drink booze up their ass so if i shove a
hater todd up there
yeah i saw train spotting that's right
i'm going way far back to high school
you're like you know in the 90s we saw
trainspotting it's a supposed to
eat and that's what a hater todd is
suppository of love
so cow tippers hater tots we're doing
uh cow dongs which are you know sausages
um
they got [ __ ] uh oat milk soft serve
because you know we do vegan and
non-vegan food and stuff
so i know when i go out there i'm just
gonna be like
just rub out my faith totally so i gotta
i gotta take control of my body speaking
of taking control of the body man
you [ __ ] ethan sapley put up a
thirsty [ __ ] photo
yeah uh where he's wearing like a a
tank top but he was like i've never worn
one of these except
under a [ __ ] secondary shirt and
stuff and he's like in [ __ ] super
shape man looks like he's got guns and
he's [ __ ] cut
so something like men's health video
like work out with ethan
it's crazy his instagram [ __ ] like
icon is him as willem so i mean it's
it's funny because you look from william
you look to him and you're like what the
[ __ ]
um he looks amazing man that kept me
from eating tonight
because i was sitting there going like
you know what i'm a goddamn man of
50 and [ __ ] i had a heart attack once
i deserved a goddamn
eat man and just as i was about to i saw
a picture of him and i was like i
couldn't wait
i can just jerk off instead
i didn't do that i smoked weed but
that'll be tonight when i get home from
this show and i'm like
oh my god i want to eat and then i'll be
like jerk off and go to bed i'll do that
now you know what my evening looks like
that's my friday night kids
[ __ ] that's why i want to become an
independent filmmaker
um hey this episode of fat man beyond is
lucky enough to have a sponsor we got a
sponsor
indeed i know how much you guys love the
ad reads yeah
[ __ ] it's important to use that look
without the average we got no show
indeed so we thank our sponsor this week
keeps
keeps uh go to keeps.com
fat man and you get your first month of
treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash fat man and you're like first free
month of treatments of what
what do they do well what's the name kev
keeps
keeps and what is it about keeping your
hair
hair ladies and gentlemen oh dudes dudes
like you know you want to keep as much
hair as you got we're middle-aged dudes
how old are you
i am 48 years old and i am 50. i'm
closer to death than mark always have
been
always willing he'll never catch up i
will beat him to the grave
um and i'll tell you something right now
my body is decaying at a regular rate
man rapidly
all my joints are going not the joints
you smoke but the joints and
all the the skin and the hair of course
naturally man hair has been going since
i was 25 go watch mall rats i remember
the first time i showed my mom mull rats
the only thing she said afterwards two
things she goes
so glad you and jay got to run around
get some exercise and the second thing
was
tiger you have a bald spot i was like
you
what really she's like yeah it's about
the size of a quarter well now it's the
size of a [ __ ] small bank in geneva
ladies and gentlemen and i wish
that keeps had existed back in the day
so i could have kept
some of that luxurious hair i used to
have hair like lion's mane
i've seen it now look at this crap look
what i'm left with the dregs
all that's left is this not magic
anymore not a lion's mane
i look like scar even he had a better
lion's mane than i got
but it wouldn't have been that way had
keeps existed man keeps won't help you
grow your damn hair that's that's nature
and god's responsibility depending on
what you believe in and stuff
what keeps is gonna do help you keep
your hair
indeed two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness
by the time they're 35 and the best way
to prevent hair loss is to do something
about it while you have the hair
left trust me kids he ain't kidding yeah
no and i i feel you like that's why i
keep it so
short because if i let it grow out into
a gorgeous luscious afro
i turn into isaac from the love boat and
there's like a toll right in the middle
of just a little island like a little
super villain lair this is a hollowed
out volcano
that's where they all go and um yeah man
look
we're [ __ ] old we know a thing or two
we may be young at heart
doing a show like fat man beyond talking
about movies and stuff
but we're old and body we're mostly
decrepit
take it from old men men who look back
at their young selves and and see what
they wish they could have corrected
this hair loss is correctable
thanks to good folk folks it keeps
they're going to grow your hair for you
they're going to help you keep your hair
i look every day i open up the medicine
cabinet and i see that old
1970s pick with the black fist at the
ball of the end
just gathering dust and cobwebs because
i got nothing to pick with it
and i don't know i ain't owned a coleman
years
i've been saving like 69 cents a year
for 20 years because
who needs a [ __ ] comb when he got a
hat you want to live under a [ __ ]
baseball cap backwards and [ __ ]
then don't use keeps you want to show
off what you got you want keep what you
got
keeps it go to keeps.com ladies and
gentlemen keeps.com
fat man you say some stuff or i'll say
some more stuff go say more stuff i'll
say more stuff
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results so
it's important to ask
act fast the sooner you start using it
the sooner you'll see
how much hair you can keep and you know
treatments start at like 10 bucks a
month even after the free treatment you
get by signing up
keeps.com oh my god if somebody told me
in my 20s if you give me 10
a month you could keep your hair i would
have blown that person
i mean never mind the money i was like
what else can i give you but 10 bucks
easily would have been worth it this is
great but i would like the 10
also yes keeps.com ladies and gentlemen
the good folks at keeps.com
gonna help you keep your hair keeps.com
slash
fat man find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors ladies and gentlemen
you get treated right at home you ain't
gotta go someplace no online doctors
they'll send prescriptions right to your
house
come on and then you you then you do it
it's on you
keep's gonna help you keep your hair go
to keeps.com
slash fat man k-e-e-p-s
dot com thank you to our sponsor keeps
and now
on with the countdown casey is coast to
coast
at number 19 this week uh all right man
i'm shooting to the top of the charts
uh what uh what have you been up to i
talked about my [ __ ] how i'm hungry and
how i'm going to chicago i'm so hungry
i'm going to the midwest
what's going on in your life uh what
i've been up to this week uh it's
it's a it's a weird nether week i think
we talked about it last week and i'm
waiting to hear back on a couple of
things
um chasing down new opportunities just
still also kind of just working on stuff
kind of so nothing's going on you had a
week nothing really because i mean
well i mean to be fair we only did the
show like two minutes ago
what's happened since then let me tell
you cold fusion
not much what has it been like we did
the show on sunday
on sunday it's now friday five days
later yeah
um i watched a little tv
we watched [ __ ] uh last time we did
the show
we neither of us had seen lovecraft
country indeed yeah you got the
the alert on your phone like your tin
it's in my queue you've since watched it
yes excuse me that was the sound of one
of the monsters
lovecraft country exploding from the
earth to protect uh
um how insanely well-written
was last week they're all insanely well
written but how insanely well-written
was last week's episode the final
moments
the the the closing circle
yeah of the jackie robinson baseball bat
moment that we saw in the very first
episode and
just such a great piece of like creative
writing
science fiction particularly creative
writing where you
have an effect on your own existence
somehow
you know and and the fact that tulsa 21
seems to be like an event that keeps on
giving yeah
that you can now attack it in mult like
i i'm not sure that that
sequence would have had quite the same
resonance
had we not already visited tulsa 21 in
watchmen
watchmen did a bit of heavy lifting for
them on the subject also saved him a
bunch of money
right because they didn't have to show
the breadth of
the like the landscape what was going on
the way watchmen like
watchmen had that opening safe and
private ryan kind of like
very much ten minute sequence where
you're like holy crap here
now the public at large seems to have
been over the course of the last year
educated more about
tulsa yeah or even learning about it for
the first time
um now they can work off the foundation
and go like okay you know about this
here's an aspect of it rather than like
we have to
teach you history just to tell you the
story right and it can drill down
much more on your character's
perspectives on it rather than just have
it be
a we're introducing you to this thing
that we know you don't know yeah a lot
of exposition um
and yeah i thought i thought it was
great i thought it was really strong and
again it's a show that's emotional
powerful but as a writer i'm just i'm
not even jealous i'm just like it just
makes me want to put my pen
down where i'm like what was i saying
jane zombob were about
to do again i should really
just retire at this point um yeah
[ __ ] it was so good so damn good yeah
i'm look i'm jealous because i saw there
were some people
on the internet who went to a uh special
secret drive-through
screening drive-in screening of this oh
finale
that would feel good on a big screen
right yeah and so i'm a little jealous
as much as i would enjoy that man still
you're listening to your car radio and
stuff which could be a cool sound system
i don't know i i my favorite way to
consume that show
is on my bed while eating for an hour
straight as i
as i detailed earlier and right now
we're friday
saturday so by sunday night it will be
um 96 hours yeah
might be ready to break my fest although
what's gonna happen is
like uh at that night i'll be like i'm
so close to eight o'clock and i don't
eat past eight o'clock so if i just wait
till tomorrow
at noon then i'll be like 100 hours into
this [ __ ] and stuff
then i'll feel really disciplined and
then
i'll sit on the bed and watch lovecraft
country but a smart man would learn his
lesson and be like
just enjoy love craft country on sunday
night no food
it's good enough it's a sumptuous
banquet enough you don't have to
you know [ __ ] pile the veggie grill
on top of it you're not going to do that
though
we'll see we'll see it's about
discipline right i will i will text you
at 8 30 and be like and see
yeah how long it takes you to answer
because i'm sorry i had a nacho all over
my fingers oh my god
smells amazing
[Laughter]
we shall see um all right in lieu of uh
us not having anything really exciting
to talk about in our lives
i'm hungry and he's bored shall we do
the news we can we can do the news
ladies and gentlemen mark well actually
kevin
i was gonna say i'm very fond of saying
mark is a news hound goes out and find
our news
but this week i feel personally
responsible for texting mark three
stories
like what a scoop which i may or may not
have already had
we already collected them but i'm like
but i mean no they're making another
spider-man
let's talk about this it's like okay you
got it tiger
thanks kev um well the the most
late-breaking news we got was
um and it's a thing that had been spoken
about before
um the milestone universe from dc comics
um which is the home of the dakota
universe
which gives you icon and rocket and
hardware and
static shock in static shock when i had
moderated the milestone panel of the dc
fandome they revealed that they were
already beginning to develop a
live-action static movie because
and and with very good reason into the
spider-verse
probably cracked that open yeah no doubt
they're like oh my god if they'll buy
miles morales
they'll totally buy stuff yeah we've got
a teenage black guy right over here yeah
and so it was it was kind of clear that
like reggie hudlun was gonna be involved
and then
warner brothers clearly because that's
where where milestone the
all the months on titles were
headquartered but today the news was
that michael b jordan
is joining static shock as a producer
and his outlier productions
company outlier society is the name of
the company
is going to be the creative home of
static shock
um i was just captured by the image of
him as killmonger
um yes great news very good news uh
probably play a role in a two somewhere
right it would not surprise me
if if there was something for michael b
jordan
a man who'll now walk between two worlds
well
has he walked between was he ever in a
dc thing he was previously in a marvel
thing
and he was in two marvel if you count
fantastic four right
and black panther black panther was he
ever
in a dc thing i think he was in a decent
first foray
yeah like crossing the streams going on
this has been like a week and a half of
lots of stream crossing
um but it's great news man very good
news and also him being involved gives
it a huge profile
huge profile you know it's it's the sort
of thing where
it's it's a crude analogy but it ends up
being used in hollywood all the time
where you say well all right listen this
studio or this production whatever is
now a little bit pregnant
with this idea that the idea that
there's no skin in the game yet that
they can kind of come and go yeah we'll
make a static movie but when michael b
jordan shows up
then it's oh all right we're a little
bit pregnant with this and so now
there's no backing out
or if we back out there's a lot of
ramifications for it you know and so
this this is a good thing
for this movie it's the best thing um
movie or you think they'll i think
they'll do movie i think
i think it's a big enough deal for them
and again
but i mean movie like in a movie theater
or do you think it would just wind up
like every other movie is going to wind
up
playing in my home uh i i think we're
far enough out
that you know they might they're they're
like this is a post-vaccine movie
i mean anything that's going into
production in the next you know
month two months three months is a
post-vaccine move yeah
um because you know and and the news has
been incredibly dire
especially from the theater chains in
the in the us
but like guys we got like four months
left of cash and then we're all going
out of business
yeah um you know in the uk some of them
are shutting down in the u.s
you know we still can't go to the movies
here can we not in los angeles no
i mean orange county you can i think
ventura county is beginning to open up
but la and san francisco are still down
can you you can't even rent a movie
theater here
like you know some people like coy
jandro he rented a movie theater for his
birthday and saw
tennant yeah but he probably had to go
out of los angeles down to like oc or
something yeah like
you have to bounce out see ladies and
gentlemen jason pop it in
well i just did it uh so amc hold on go
back to us real quick
listen to this [ __ ] brag right
the guy just did it
go back to jay-z before he yells mark
pointed it out
two weeks ago that one of his friends
did it in huntington beach
so amc just started doing what regal or
whoever it was
um so you either have to go to orange
county riverside or
thousand oaks a thousand oaks which is
ventura county right over the line
but at amc you can rent the theater for
a hundred bucks
for up to 20 people and like
you know i haven't taken uh jen out on a
date
since uh covet hit because she's been
pregnant
but we rented a theater we're gonna go
see jurassic park next week
so you can see jurassic park um uh
empire strikes back
they have all sorts of old school like
favorites that you can check out and a
ton of
horror movies for halloween so it's like
if you're in la it's like what a
40-minute drive out to thousand oaks why
not
yeah that's some [ __ ] that's a good
date tip right there
from jc man owner of this here
establishment scum and
villainy canteen why don't you rent this
[ __ ] out for 100 bucks a night
give people like you know the lone day
um
you should do the same thing steal that
idea there's
no indoor dining well nobody you're not
giving them food
they could just come in and play a movie
yeah
same [ __ ] thing right like if you
ever wanted to rent out just double up
though 100 bucks seems low
that seems like a [ __ ] deal and a
half do you think they'll do that in
los angeles when the theaters reopen uh
because that is how i'll
i mean i'm not it's the only i'm not
saying i'm a coastal elite but that's
how i'm
paying to see a movie every time from
now on here's my hundred dollars
i'd like a theater to myself please yeah
i mean you can't do it
unless the county is is on the whatever
scale of opening it up
is allowed to open movie theaters so la
he couldn't rent out to come and
villainy because la's not
allowed to open restaurants yet are you
a restaurant
yeah we're technically a restaurant so
we could be open
if we had that look let's be honest that
that depends who you ask
if you've ever had the food it's coming
to the village
um so if we had an outdoor area
it would we could be open and serve
people outside
but because we're on the hollywood walk
of fame yes
there's no place for us to expand out to
because we'd have our
our tables on top of sid grum and star
and that
you know we can't do that but wait like
couldn't you could you you know how like
i saw on the news a couple weeks ago
somebody airbnb in the last blockbuster
where you could airbnb it where you
could like pay to spend the night
at the blockbuster they got a bed there
in a bedroom and [ __ ] oh that's
interesting
can you airbnb this [ __ ] we could
probably airbnb
it i know um i'm working on
with a toy company turning this into
a toy store for the holidays oh
so [ __ ] smart from thanksgiving till
new year's you'll be able to come here
and i can't say
which toy company it is but it's a very
cool high-end toy company that's great
and you're going to be able to come in
here
and take photos with life-size versions
of
their toys and all sorts of things like
and then buy gifts
for christmas so that's what i'm working
on now that's cool that is
that's a [ __ ] scoop why didn't you
tell us that's a good thing you just did
tell us still working on it
that's [ __ ] hot uh but also airbnb
this place who wouldn't want to [ __ ]
in scum and villainy cantina you put up
a cot in the middle of the floor
kill the cameras and you can't work that
day
and then you know [ __ ] whatever
happens it will be very much scum and
villainy
yeah putting the scum in scum and
villainy
you could sell them here it's a hundred
bucks a night
but the add-ons are where you make the
money like they gotta use your condom
the scum bag for a hundred bucks a pop
and if they're doing it they're probably
gonna have sex twice that's 200 bucks
don't let married people in because they
don't use like trust me
we could uh we could uh rent out
costumes also
[ __ ] yeah like we could get a the uh hut
slayer leia costume and we could get the
the lake who for if you wanted to you
know
dress up like a twilight see there we go
now i'm thinking here's the guy i was
thinking there's you know there's a
world in which you could also rent this
place out as a location for porn
that's there you go i mean
come and villainy
[Laughter]
oh my god let's shoot a porno oh wait i
did that one yeah star [ __ ]
two still that's the you know you know
it's been tough for jc because he can't
open and [ __ ]
obviously he's got a bar and what he
considers a restaurant and the city
and the city won't let them open and
stuff
desperate times call for desperate
measures they do now
is the time for us to pool our resources
and our talents
and shoot a pornographic movie right
here at the scum and villainy cantina
we can start a kickstarter who wants to
be in our pornography
who wants to be involved who wants to
back our movie
um but who would fault us because it'll
save scum and villainy cantina
indeed there's also a lot of people who
have met and gotten engaged here
right and so they'll wouldn't you want
to
you know we could do small marriage we
could live stream the marriage you could
marry them and then they could [ __ ]
drag me into this
stadium happy to do that as well uh stay
the night and
consummate where they at in the spot
they met all right
so what you're saying is for let's say
2 000 bucks you get the overnight
marriage package where
you come here i marry them
uh then it's their place and then we
live stream the wedding
and then the place then we turn over the
keys
like i now pronounce you man and wife
you may kiss the bride and here are the
keys to scum and villainy
turn it into [ __ ] and villainy and then
we all [ __ ] off well we leave the stream
on
that's the pornography part that's where
we make the real money because we're
like we tell them afterwards for ten
thousand we don't release the stream
um no so that's [ __ ] that's a pretty
good deal somebody in the chat said
it would be we could call it zack and
mary the comeback
oh i like that come back to her i like
that
um all right put that on the menu man
anybody out there willing to pay 2 000
bucks get married by me here it's coming
villainy cantina and then
spend the night where you consummate uh
your marriage
on a [ __ ] star wars bed now you gotta
build one of those
a star wars bed with star wars sheets on
it right
we get those off ebay and then you get
to keep the sheets two thousand bucks
right
i mean obviously you just pull out one
of these booths you put in an inflatable
mattress
and then shaban that's good actually he
ain't [ __ ] wrong
you could even tent one of these [ __ ]
you know with like lace and [ __ ] i mean
and glowing the dark stars for when you
bring all the lighting down
you could tent all of them and turn into
like a tiny hotel
so that's two thousand dollars two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
what do you think they all want to [ __ ]
in front of each other
kind of sick people are these people are
you campers
um yeah man there's many different ways
for us to monetize this space
come in villainy's love hotel yes
what what is the you will never find a
more wretched hive of love and villainy
you'll never find
[Laughter]
as long as you live
someone who [ __ ] you that's
commandability
two thousand bucks it's not a bad deal
it's not a bad deal i'm just trying to
franchise
back now and it's one thousand bucks act
later it's three thousand bucks yeah
so you see a pattern here
um all right so michael michael b jordan
michael b jordan is making status it's
gonna be been producing static shock
hooray and we're gonna be producing a
[ __ ] hotel right here
[Laughter]
so it's kind of the same thing you can
see how like we feel like
we're in the same category as michael b
jordan indeed um the rumor of the week
this week um which feels less like rumor
and probably a thing that's totally
going to happen
but has not been confirmed is that for
spider-man 3
um uh home skillet uh
i'm just kidding home slice this movie
is shaping up to be
the greatest marvel movie ever made with
the with the story lines with the names
with the they they talked about having
smith
the spider slayer in the story which
means
robots fighting spider-man killing
robots
like okay spider-slayer
but in any event yes the rumor is that
in addition
to bringing the villain from the amazing
spider-man 2
jamie foxx's electro right um which
automatically like
weird and muddles up the the time
streams
there's a rumor that will also get two
previous spider-men
tobin mcguire and the other one andrew
garfield
andrew i mean fingers crossed for
nicholas hammond but something's telling
me that's not going to cost
classic um yeah
i've been reading this and then i read
sony was like this is not confirmed but
it feels like it's gonna happen i mean
it feels like there's this weird
race between the flash and spider-man
three for like
all of your nostalgia books i mean
it's so weird that we're living in this
like multiverse arms race
where we all win we all benefit we all
win from this escalation but uh i
i'm all for it uh this is great i hope
it's one scene
maybe even one shot uh i'm all for it
but it's not what's going to get me to
go to that
movie everything else has me hooked for
that movie
like they don't have to be like and
guess what the other two spiderman are
going to be there i'm like whatever
that's fine i'm happy if it happens i
know that'll make a lot of people happy
but that ain't my driver
my driver is just it sounds like it's
the sinister six
it sounds like they're making a sinister
six movie man it's gonna be
[ __ ] amazing and him on the run
i didn't see this coming when i saw the
end of the last movie i was just like i
can't wait to see him
you know go to the prom next year or
graduate and instead
he ain't graduating he's graduated to
hell
man a minute amen
they had me from the moment you know he
was like oh [ __ ]
you know not just because he almost
cursed but because i was like now that's
some [ __ ] storytelling i couldn't
have predicted that
so i want to see them put peter parker
through the ringer man
because uh i want to see them do born
again
with peter parker essentially remember
what they did to matt murdock and
what kingpin did to matt murdock and
born again that's what i hope happens to
spider-man here gets broken [ __ ] down
and then
discovers who he really is because think
about it you can't go back with you
exactly come on spider-man
that's the whole movie has to be the
equivalent of that come on spider-man
come on spider-man oh [ __ ] you're gonna
make me cry
goddammit that's a beautiful moment yeah
um all right
anyway so yeah they could throw in those
other two cats it's totally fine i get
it that's smart
throw that [ __ ] shot in the trailer
who ain't going but
that's not what's dragging me they they
had me at
oh [ __ ] that that movie just seems like
ballsy storytelling particularly for
like you know
something that they mint money on you
know they could just keep doing
variations on the same [ __ ] theme but
instead they're growing the story like
we're seeing we're going to see
a version of spider-man we never saw
before spider-man outlaw spider-man on
the run spider-man like with all the
[ __ ] heroes in his universe
none being able to be like with the
exception apparently doctor strange
none there to help him because he's a
[ __ ] criminal yeah
spider-man homeless it's got to be right
i mean that's got to be the name that's
a good idea right um
all right what else we got um we talked
i don't know
three months ago two months ago 48
months ago
um that uh that george miller
he ye uh legendary filmmaker guy who
made
babe pig in the city indeed amongst
other things
yes a guy who made happy feet yes
um uh he we we
all wanted after seeing um
mad max free road a sequel another film
in that world we wanted to
to follow max we wanted to follow
furiosa we wanted to see you know
how that world would expand he was like
[ __ ] that i want to go back to the
future
and he's doing a furiosa origin story
without charlize without shirley's with
anya taylor joy
but he's also adding thor and dr
manhattan
yeah wait isn't she in
uh new mutants she is yes so there you
go
you got the whole uh you got two marvel
kids and a dc
god more or less um all right i'll see
it i'm
look george miller directing it george
miller directed totally
who what is she from that i don't know
other than that
new music um she was in the witch the
vivovich
that movie the witch the witch that's
her big thing she was in that she was in
glass
um glass yeah really yeah
i didn't see that either i guess yeah
she was the uh the sort of heroine
the the because when what's his face
james mcavoy's
weird sybil like character was taking a
bunch of young women hostage
she was kind of the final girl of that
dynamic
she's the one who escapes she's the one
who defeats the bad guy
was she in the other movie split
or she actually yeah she's i'm confusing
glass and split she's in both she's in
both
but yes the first she's part of the m
night shyamalan hero verse
indeed whatever the shamalani verse
shyamalan the verse
the night verse the m night a verse
we'll shorten that yeah we took it we
took a few drafts we got there
um all right well good for her she's
playing furiosa she is
do you think they'll get charlie's do
wrap-around sequences to be like
when i was a girl and then cut to her
i remember when yeah [ __ ] before we
had those that [ __ ] one time where we
drove in a straight line to get gas
things happen to me in my life
i would like her to be the uh the feral
kid of the road warrior
oh [ __ ] because the feral kid you know
grows up to have been the narrator of
the whole story
so like yeah let's just have charlize
come back um before i met max
that was enough i'm in but george
millard takes a minute
he is not always speediest filmmaking
yeah yeah he takes his time
good for him because he makes wonderful
films but i'm sure we'll be seeing
this in what 2028 you know
if we're lucky yeah as with all things
if we're lucky and it's just called
furiosa so far
good enough yep i'll take it not mad max
colon furiosa
well i i mean technically max as far as
we know is not in it he's not gonna be
on it
unless chris hemsworth is playing young
max
who met her before he met her uh perhaps
unless they're telling two different
stories unless it's there's no way
hemsworth is playing
he's playing tomorrow
[Laughter]
he's playing somebody that she loved who
definitely didn't make it into the next
movie into
into uh fury road yeah this is my
favorite part of the show where we guess
what's going on
okay so it's hemsworth the good guy the
bad guy or is yaya abdulmatine in the
second
the good guy the bad guy let us find out
indeed
uh what do we got next we have and i did
some research
to figure out how to pronounce her name
sochi gomez
is joining dr strange the multiverse of
madness
which uh a lot of people uh they haven't
announced who
she's playing no but a lot of people
think she's playing america right
america chavez
uh and i saw some people online were
like hey man she doesn't look like
american chavez to me
she's too light to be american chavez
but uh we don't even know if she's
playing american child
we have no idea who she's playing she is
like
[ __ ] good for her man yeah um
all this says to me is jesus every time
they tell us
a story about marvel's future the
universe just keeps getting bigger
they're adding characters um you know
smart like [ __ ] they got a bunch of
characters to choose from
now they're adding the young ones and it
feels like they're lining up
young avengers in the future i feel like
they they're they're definitely
broadening where where the other movies
began to sort of contract
right like there was the early explosion
of less than jews this character this
character this character let's drop this
character in another sequel of that
thing
but it was definitely drawing to an
event
that would consolidate everything and
now it seems as if it's the big bang
like on the other side of of infinity
war it was an end game
just boosh we're getting all of this
stuff
and whether it will eventually narrow
back down into some other event at some
point
who knows but for now it's it's a galaxy
of stars
some event involving kang no doubt could
be indeed
ma'am in a minute but yes so she's
joining doctor strange
uh bennett guang and she would tell ego
four are also expected to reprise their
roles
as coming back and carl mordo is coming
back
mordo what do i say mordu is
too many sorcerers and elizabeth olsen
is also going to be in this as the
scarlet witch yeah i'm wondering if uh
she goes you know crazy in one division
and she's the bad guy
or bad girl the big bad if you will in
multiverse of madness it could very well
be because down for that man if like
that was the
she became an avengers level threat and
stuff i could see that arc because you
saw her at the end of end game being
like
bombed and [ __ ] yeah and you know that
one division will feed into what's
happening in in multiple ways
somebody i don't know who it was i don't
i think they're in the cast but they're
like they said wanda vision
is a flat out action movie wow
like it's a action movie with little
sitcom
beats um so i can't wait uh look i was
already on board but [ __ ] when does that
happen
um they their production is supposed to
begin
in next year no when does one division
happen no one division debuts in
december
in december yeah and uh a mandalorian is
two weeks
mendo is like the day before halloween
this is the way
mundo mondo watching the [ __ ] out of
that man then i also read that
favreau said they're going to start
shooting
season 3 before the end of 2020.
yes did you read it in my news no you
pulled that
well done how awesome is that
yeah just keeps going oh more baby yoda
more baby yoda baby yoda will save us
all and he will but i mean because
mandalorian like
of all of the shows that are trying to
figure out a way to covet proof
themselves
yeah it was almost by design
not quite coveted proof but coveted
resistant
coveted retardant why because it's all
on a sound stage there's no location
yeah you're indoors
you're indoors on location at least
you're outdoors i understand why people
think this is safer because it's like
you're still going inside a building
you're still going inside like if it'd
be safer if they were like we shoot it
outdoors all day long then it's like oh
great [ __ ] no wonder yeah but i mean
you've been on a location there's
200 people milling around the location
there's like look at these
looky-loos and bystanders and like that
what they think they're cutting down on
i mean i hate to be this guy but what
[ __ ] star wars location has ever had
looky loose they go out to like the
desert or [ __ ] snow
lands or the middle of the ocean [ __ ]
but they still had dudes with long
lenses getting shots of [ __ ] in
the sand
yeah like i just i just like i'm
maybe i'm ignorant but i'm like i don't
understand why everybody's wow
this show's covet proof or a covet
better i'm like why they're still
indoors on a soundstage like they have a
smaller crew is that the philosophy
um i think so that would be it i mean
believe me i'm not like you better
answer this because it's not like you
got the answer but
it always strikes me as odd when they're
like and this show is particularly
coveted friendly or coped-free and i'm
like why because
because he's got a mask on he never
takes it off cut back to us
god damn it that was just laying there
neither of us [ __ ] got it
neither you nor me the new host of this
show
funny man jc ladies and gentlemen um but
actually one of the things i've been
doing to
pay for my house while kovit's been
happening
is virtual video villages
so via zoom all of the executives and
money people who always sit in video
village
on set during a movie or a tv show or
commercial
we've found a way to virtualize that so
they dial in from home on zoom
and they have two-way communication with
uh
a director on set and so they can talk
to
the director and then the director can
parlay
what any concerns that the producers and
those people have
so if you're not actually hands-on
equipment right
all of those type of the money people
the marketing people
now can sit at home on zoom and actually
see what the camera is seeing in real
time without having to be without having
to be there so you can actually
cut 60 percent of
looky loose and hanger on off set
that way and i know a guy who shot an
episode of mandalorian and he said that
he wasn't even there yeah really like he
dp'ed from a distance
using this [ __ ] or whatever like so
yeah i guess i guess that's it that's
how they so it's not so much that like
man we got a [ __ ] bead on how to do
it right they're just
like we're doing what everyone else is
doing we're keeping everybody offset
i don't know if you've got other ideas
hit us up in the chat room
jc will let us know maybe there's
somebody that's like what you're not
thinking of
jackass is this but i'm really
disappointed that neither of us
thought of the mask everybody's wearing
a mask um and also it's a show that
doesn't really require lots of smooching
you know i think that's a that's a big
problem with a lot of
dramas and whatever like grey's anatomy
like holy [ __ ] we gotta do a bunch of
surgeries roll up close on people
there's romantic scenes all of that now
becomes a different
problem to have to solve whereas
mandalorian as far as i can tell
not a ton of kissing lots of like i'm
gonna shoot you from across the room
great
god you just made me think for the first
time like
so what they're not shooting any porn
now right oh no they're shooting porn
they'll always shoot porn
even in the middle of this pandemic if
if you're endemic
if anybody's good at testing on a very
regular basis that's a good point it's
important
good point somebody out there is making
out
i'm pouring sets porn sense uh what else
we got
um let's see moving right along
remember how excited we were about going
to see coming to america
yes coming to to america yes
yes i know this news and i'm excited
about this guy and tell him i'm crazy
excited because coming to america is
coming home
instead of the theaters to us that's
right man who
amazon amazon on december 18th bought it
from paramount for 125 million dollars
what yep what was the budget i wonder
because they had to make a little bit on
top in order to make it worth their
while
you know i i don't know that's a that's
it that's a figure such a brilliant move
though
i applaud amazon for this uh or any
streamer who was like give us that movie
because it's done and they ain't gonna
be able to come out for a damn minute
and when we all know that
when the box office reopens it's gonna
be like superhero movies big ass
blockbusters and stuff this is going to
make christmas
excellent it's going to make christmas
great and you know i know
the the industry itself is a little
tepid on this idea of like
these giant theatrical blockbusters
coming home first blowing up the
theatrical window
all that but we have to have a release
valve
yeah for a socially so that we don't you
know
shoot each other in the face but also
even the business
if every movie waits until we can go
back to the movies that means then
you're gonna have a traffic jam
every weekend there will be eight giant
blockbusters to go see
nobody's gonna be able to make all the
money back because you have half of a
population who has no jobs
you know like it it becomes an untenable
situation either way so the only way to
kind of make it workable
is to be able to release your mulans
your disney soul which is also coming to
disney plus
i saw yeah the second trailer the new
trailer they put up is really wonderful
coming to america is coming out you know
pushing everything
into 2021 feels like it's you know
you're hedging your bets
but some of that smart money is giving
it to people now
and the way that disney did it with
mulan is like hey you know payloads or
something something
what what do you think prime's gonna do
is that they just put it on prime for
free or i think they'll put transactions
because i think you know they don't
technically need the money
for them uh amazon prime video well
you're already paying for prime so if
they gave you coming to america
to be like this is what this is a prize
this is what you get right this is why
we value you as a customer and amazon's
entire television
slash theatrical initiative is like a
vanity project
for jeff bezos and the rest of amazon
yeah they're in the paper towel selling
business
100 they're they're not necessarily in
your
look guys we made a movie we wish you
would see it like hey just
you have this too they're like uh we
also have toilet paper
and coming to america right and jeans
and car batteries like they it's just
another product they sell yeah you know
i mean there there is a
version of the future in which both
amazon and netflix
looking at the state of the theatrical
business and how every theatrical chain
at least in america is starting to
crumble under the financial burden
sweep in and say hey you know what we
did with bookstores and supermarkets
we're not doing with movie theaters i
really suspect that's in the future
because who else can afford to buy these
giant places yeah
and you know who else has a rooting
interest in entertainment
to some degree then like yeah and owning
all of it yeah you know it's it's it is
somehow both inevitable and insidious at
the same time
yeah but it's going to happen it's going
to happen
get ready kids anyway what's next better
news
and better news well there's nothing
better than [ __ ] coming to america
coming to amazon
in december i can't [ __ ] wait is
going to be fantastic
um we have previously talked about a
marvel casting a bit of news
um sochi gomez joining doctor strange
too
there was a bit of casting that we
speculated about seems to have been
confirmed
previously is that tatiana maslany was
going to play
jen walters she-hulk yeah in the new
series the internet told us that
and so did mark ruffalo yeah roughly
when he was like
and he was like yeah welcome to the
families welcome to the hogwarts or
whatever
and uh it seems as if maybe
we're all a little early maybe there was
gun jumping happening maybe there was uh
you know leaping out ahead some offsides
play
because in an interview with the sudbury
star i'm not sure where that is
um canada i think sudbury yeah lovely
garden municipality um
she claimed that the casting reports
about her playing she-hulk aren't true
her quote that actually isn't a real
thing and it's like a press release
that's gotten out of hand
it's totally i've been connected to
these things in the past and the press
has gotten into it
but it's not actually a thing
unfortunately
now i hate to be this guy mark
but are we sure that's tatiana mizlami
saying that
and not one of her orphan black
personalities
it could have been the russian one
it's possible um and also like
there have been casting notices that
have gone out in the past that proved
not to be accurate
true this one seemed legit though it
seemed like once mark ruffalo got on
board you were like oh maybe
he feeds the hulk right he's in the
marvel family if
he didn't know who would some people
have speculated this could be a
uh contract negotiation ploy
but according to the actress herself
she's like no ploy this is just there's
it's not true right you know which
again could be some you know i'm not
going to say nefarious plot to dissuade
and deceive
but it could be a tactic it could just
be a the ink isn't signed yet i am not
authorized to confirm or deny so i guess
i'll just deny
and there had been a moment a couple
years back when like matt smith from
doctor who was cast in a star wars movie
and then never appeared in the star wars
movie yeah that's true you know so like
these things get announced
and don't come to fruition for any
number of reasons well let's hope
that uh the first rumor is true
and that that part she has
for keeps that's right keeps.com
slash fat man ladies and gentlemen
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash batman however if you're a
woman do not use cubes no
don't use it um for dudes if if you're
looking to keep a part
in your hair keeps.com
slash fat man thank you nice
um all right from the haves and the have
nots to what because we don't know what
she is at this point whether she has the
role or whether she has not the role um
we go to star trek
we just wrote that ourselves right now
i'm feeling full with courage in my
chest i'm feeling out of breath and
hungry
singing that song took a lot out of me
it made me lightheaded makes me think i
should be having a meal um
um even if it was like a meal on the
hollow deck
where it was fake and i was like this
air tastes delicious
and i'm dressed as a 20s gangster piece
of the action see
star trek discovery's third season
premiere was just this past week
that is star trek colon the cbs
all-access app show yes
it's called discovery yes better known
as disco
because that lasts forever is that right
is that a thing well yes they call it
disco they call it disco
for that reason no i just think they
shortened discovery to disco
like that's cool isn't it because nobody
ever hated disco
wow good point so soon they're gonna
have the
bunch of copies of this [ __ ] show at
shea stadium roanoke
burning them and [ __ ] light them on fire
um
what are they doing with this was it
chase stadium where'd they do it
chicago where wrigley field in chicago
kaminsky park in chicago
you mean where movies is headed october
30th to november 6th the very same
at st lou's assembly in the loop yeah
don't say
one of my favorite jokes from childhood
was told to me by my father when we went
to chicago for the first time when i was
17
1979 when i was nine years old and uh
he said um you know he was like the
train here is called the loop
and it's elevated they call it the l
train because it's elevated and it's
called the loop
and you know as a kid you're like wow he
told you all that so he could tell you
the joke
and the joke was a guy gets into a
taxi cab and says hey buddy does this
car go to the loop
and then the cab driver said no man it
goes beep
deacon you're from illinois that joke
play
no taking shaking his head no i really
should have said
he's shaking his head yes but he just
gave us a grim
midwestern no don't do it don't bring
that joke to chicago kevin i'm bringing
it
because i'm going to be there with jay
there's a hobiespopup.com
there was a hobo in the town i grew up
in on long island in baldwin
who would always walk up and down the
street as we were like in high school
and he'd walk into the deli that we were
all ordering sandwiches from
and he would say i'm horny for states
what's delaware in idaho alaska
do it again break it down slow this new
information for me
you've had a lifetime to get used to
this this is the first time i'm hearing
it okay hold on there's obviously what
pun
in word playing bob lots of them uh i'm
horny for states
i'm horny for states that's the premise
that's the premise
what's delaware in delaware
idaho idaho alaska
[ __ ] where was that kind of learning
when i was in school i still don't know
the 50 states
but if somebody was like here's how you
learn them through pornographic terms
like listen you can either watch the
animaniacs they'll run you right through
them all
or crazy hobo wisdom gotten in the deli
um he had a bindle stick i think his
name was eddie we called him crazy eddie
did he have a bundle stick mm-hmm that
that's like literally jet hobo
yeah i mean it's the last of the hobos
if you look in
[ __ ] uh the dictionary next to hobo
the picture is a dude with a bundle
stick
wow have bindle will travel reads the
card of a hobo
um wait what was that so yeah disco
so what's going on with star trek uh i i
first the one show that i watched this
week was the premiere of star trek
discovery star trek disco
star trek disco which i was really
really impressed by oh
um had you not been impressed by the
previous two season openers um
here and there the first season's a
little bit of a mess the second season
kind of found itself
but the third season uh takes a giant
roll of the dice and
and the second season ends with we have
this crazy knowledge that would ruin the
federation in starfleet if it ever got
out
the only way to protect humanity as we
know it is for
me captain you know commander michael
burnham and the crew of the discovery
to launch ourselves into the distant
future in the wormhole to make sure that
nothing happens
to the present and so they do and you
open up season
three with we're coming out of the
wormhole whoa
and then they land to discover that the
federation is all but
gone like and and warp travel
has been knocked off the the table by a
thing called the burn where every
lithium crystal just spontaneously
exploded like 150 years ago
and so it now seems to be a show that's
not about trying to get back to where we
came from
we're trying to rebuild the thing that's
lost in the present
and i was like that is pretty that's a
clever idea yeah it's a smart idea it's
clever it gets you a whole brand new
series of
of circumstances and rules and
regulations and a giant quest your
heroes have to to
to complete without it feeling as if
we're just time traveling to solve a
problem then go back to where we came
from right
um so yeah i was i was super impressed
by it they're gonna rename it star trek
colon gilligan's island
[Applause]
[Laughter]
three hour tour um and apparently
cbs is happy enough with it and the the
ratings for
however you measure ratings on cbs
alexis were strong enough that it
already got renewed for a fourth season
oh
really that wasn't planned you know
before it even debuted
it was a naturally organically occurring
thing totally they're about to
you actually sold season three to me
that sounds dope i watched that episode
i
literally bought the cbs all-access app
to watch star trek discovery
and i watched a few but i was really put
off by how convoluted
the klingons were remember we talked
about that is way too much
[ __ ] makeup yeah this is very extra
yeah
like calm down so i might i might check
on season you are too loud now that i'm
over it i might check on the opening of
season three based on your review
that's what i like about this show you
learn new [ __ ] every now and again
new information um
the the you know they're making a lego
star wars holiday special
yes they've released the artwork uh
already um
adorable idea and it turns out that it
might not completely suck
oh i'm sure it'll be good all the lego
shit's very funny
yeah but you know one of the reasons why
it doesn't seem like it'll suck
then again the first one very much
sucked and they still had lots of people
who took part
but kelly marie tran anthony daniels
billy d williams have joined the voice
cast
of course already joining you know star
wars clone wars cast members matt lanter
tom kane james arnold taylor
and d bradley baker wow um it's unclear
if you're going to get your oscar isaacs
and your john boyegas or your daisy
ridleys
but those characters are in it so
who knows i mean i just want a lot of b
arthur and life day jokes they better
have a brand new boba fett cartoon
why do you think when are they finally
just gonna like because disney owns all
this [ __ ] when are they finally just
gonna like break down and be like
here's the real star wars holiday
special i don't know man because the one
who kept it from the world was george
lucas but you don't own it anymore
no so if i'm disney i'm just like come
on we already
we already made that [ __ ] you know he
already hates us yeah we already made
three movies and can't stand let's
[ __ ] what are we holding out for
um maybe next christmas but i'm telling
you 2020 would have been the year
oh yeah like if you're gonna take out
the trash in any year like
just come on just drop it on like a
friday don't tell anybody about it until
then i'll just watch it on
youtube so i'm sure it's somewhere on
the the mossy vhs that i still have
buried in the garage what about so uh
you're gonna watch it
i i will watch it um probably more out
of professional curiosity
than like die hard interest but like huh
let's see what this is it's free it's on
disney playing off freeway
for disney plus might as well watch it
get my money's worth
i mean once i finish watching the cat
from outer space i might as well
watch the movie ripe for the remaking
you think so oh god are you kidding me
kids love
cats they do kids love outer space
kids will love a cat from outer space
just great title can we get paul rudd to
voice something maybe the cat
he's got to be the human that the cat
interacts with think so yeah i think so
we can get moranis back the cat the
voice of the cat has to be
jack black no
you gotta go like elizabeth banks
tiffany haddish
tiffany haddish wow i've been watching
i just oh cause she was the voice in the
lego movie too she was the
the alien who came to earth sparkle
whatever her name was yeah yeah
um i've been watching the new girl um on
netflix
have you ever seen the new girl show the
the new girl
yes with with zoe de chanel yeah that
old show yeah
it's on netflix i've been binging it
really why it
a goes down real easy okay um
b jake johnson i'm sort of i do like him
i've been rediscovering the magic that
is jake johnson i do like him very much
um i just got to the prince episode of
new girl where they all somehow get
invited to a party at prince's house
and the scene where zoe deschanel and
jake johnson
first encounter prince and they're like
just kind of like really tense and weird
and he's like oh i'm sorry i didn't give
you time to freak out now
you may do so is it really prince it's
really prince like they shot an episode
with prince who's playing prince
and they haven't been able to say i love
you to each other and so prince is the
romantic counselor that helps them
you know grow closer together right but
jake johnson's freak out at being able
to freak out
in front of prince is the most amazing
piece of physical comedy
it's so good um what a season season
three
and it's what's called prince episode uh
it's just called prince
wow what a weird unlikely of all the
things i thought you might [ __ ] plug
tonight
the new girl was not anywhere on the
list no and i only did so because
tiffany haddish appears
as like damon wayans juniors's like one
night booty call
for an episode and maybe the first time
i'd ever seen her
but wouldn't have recognized him that's
[ __ ] tiffany haddish
playing just a honey that he doesn't
sleep with this episode
she's been around since before her
moment indeed
yeah she she wasn't ready yet but you
ready now
well done um all right we're done with
that star wars holiday special we are
i got one last news story this is the
final news story of the night ladies and
gentlemen uh grab your socks and hose
and pull here we go
i went i went a different way than i
thought it would in the middle
well you started you brought up the new
girl so i just grab your socks and grab
your hoes
i thought we're grabbing something else
entirely um and bring them to the common
villainy cantina
where you can rent out one of these four
fabulous booths
for sex with your loved one did you not
bring sheets
rent a scumbag a sleeping bag for two
um now i am assuming that your your
sunday night viewing is automatically um
lovecraft country
um food orgy and then the vow i don't
watch food orgy oh i
i have a food orgy while i'm watching
yes
i don't watch it i live food originally
nice a little bit and then i watch it
actually the way it goes in our house my
wife is like
let's ease him with the vow then go for
it with lovecraft country because
lovecraft country is very
intense and indeed there's a lot of
yelling
at the screen there's a lot of
applauding when you're watching the show
out loud
so it's a very engaging engagement so
it starts she likes to start soft with
the vow and then move into lovecraft
country which
to be fair i eat through the hour of the
vow as well
so on sunday night it's two hours
straight of eating while hbo
shows me stuff excellent um and so the
you're caught up in the valley you've
been watching
i'm very current on the vow and uh i
it's well made
i can't believe how much footage they
have but it really does feel like
they're pulling the taffy at this point
it feels like it could have wrapped up
two episodes ago but what do i know
yeah it feels like it would have been
twice as effective at half the length
agreed but i mean the good news is it's
about to come to an end and when it's
over it's over right mark
sure because why would you not gather
the writers together and make up a
second season of the vow
wait there's more there's more vow so
the idea is
i would assume and we haven't seen the
end of the vowel
but i assume that it ends with keith
vernier going to jail
because we know that's what happens in
real life but i guess if next week is
the last episode
there's not they're not even close yet
to putting this dude behind bars and
they're also not even close
with the india oxenberg storyline which
we also now know that she got out
so i guess there is lots of potential
and room for season two
i just wish they had wrapped it all up
in season one yeah i mean season one
will likely end with the arrest of keith
rainier
and then season two season two is the
trial of keith mourinho i guess that
makes sense
plus an exclusive view into ranieri's
innermost circle
all of which will be happening after the
stars documentary
which is now just india oxenburg story
which starts like next week i think
because
apparently this is like the
menendez brothers um well
they're they're certainly trying to make
it so
and again like i think the vow has been
an amazing watch by virtue of the fact
that
it's not the story it's not like we
branded people
like we already heard that part it's the
amount of footage they have
the access they have to this guy over
[ __ ] 10
12 years where you get to see everything
that well not everything but a lot of
[ __ ] that he said and the [ __ ] that took
hold and why these people like
devoted so much time to him um but it
did it felt
a little like you know stretched out
yeah
and so maybe next season only eight
episodes i don't know look i'm sure
you know what they're doing i'm sure
they're like we've been insanely
successful
go [ __ ] yourself yoga hosers um
which is their nickname for me did you
did you hear
what the india the four episodes of
india
india's stars series is about though
no apparently when alison mack was
arrested
india was the one who was like like i'm
gonna take all your stuff to storage i'm
going to take care of it
so when you get out everything's taken
care of and there was a
box of flash drives and some personal
items
she goes oh i can't put this in storage
so she brought it home with her
and after a few months she was like
what's on these flash drives and it is
keith renery
detailing all of the horrible stuff
that he wants dos to achieve pick out
only the hottest girls
i want my initials in the brand the box
here
so it's it is the like smoking
the unspoken gun yeah the like the
really
juicy meaty like you got this guy
admitting he's just scummy so that's
apparently what that
series is now you got me [ __ ] hyped
for the stars
man i want to watch that [ __ ] i think
it debuts
so next sunday is the last episode of
the vow and then the india
thing happens concurrently yeah
it's it's from the watch i'd like to see
that take down it's a lot of nexium
it is and and it doesn't i mean you know
i hate to diminish it but it doesn't
seem to be like
much story beyond like you know these
people believed a guy
and then suddenly when he started
branding people people were like hey
maybe this ain't a good thing
right and it's over did you ever see
that documentary i think we talked about
it maybe last year three identical
strangers
yeah like fascinating that's a story
that like every 10 minutes there's some
new shoe that drops that completely
changes the story and the trajectory of
that
of that narrative where that i'd have
bought that as a [ __ ] ten
episode documentary because each one
could have spread it out you could have
spread it out there's enough story
there's enough tapi they were famous
like there's footage of them like the
the
concision of that the condensed nature
of that made it so compelling
whereas the weird like the seduction of
footage
of of at the very least a vow is like
i get it you have footage of any
oxenburg making fruit juice
but like did this really need to be here
they look they're they do have footage
of indy oxenburg making for or
catharines
making fruit juice so if that's your
thing
the vow is on hbo right now
um it's well done it's incredibly well
done but it just
felt stretched out and but knowing and
then when you said season two i'm like
what
but if it's like okay now it's the trial
of this guy
i'm i'm i'll watch it but uh i gotta say
this stars india oxenberg documentary
sounds pretty
yeah and it's also so weird in that you
could 100
just google it and figure out what
happens yeah you know it's not as if
they have information that's not
publicly available
true the whole time i've been watching
it my wife's just like oh my god what
happens i'm like we know what happens
like and if you don't google it like
this is an old story
but it's presented in such a way that
it's compelling because they're like
here's
footage of wallet was going on inside
footage they had a shot of him last week
of keith ranieri in the show
where he was just walking real fast like
you know
even the fast like who why was this
necessary why did he want this shot like
him just walking around the neighborhood
um pride goes before the fall indeed um
all right that's all the news that's all
it is my friend give it up for mark you
got your news man
j.c i'm hungry
for questions all right i'm actually not
hungry but i'm boy i'd like to eat
so give me some questions we had one
really good joke in the chat
while you guys were doing your your dad
jokes okay
it was uh and it's topical it's where is
the bathroom on the millennium falcon
in sabacc in sabac
star wars i had to do it i'm going to be
a dad in a month
that's right you get to make those jokes
one month away from
uh from baby jc from jc junior if you
will
yeah jcjr yeah well it's a girl so
still call her jc jr
one what is your what does jc stand for
james
christopher so your middle name is
christopher yes
um so you just name her jane christopher
jamie justine it could be jamie but my
brother's wife is
jamie jane man my [ __ ] tarzan and
janet miss reifenberg if you're nasty
um in any event that's cute dad joke
uh i liked it i like my two-to-to-loop
better [ __ ] deacon [ __ ] all over
with a look not even a word he he's such
disdain for that joke he wasn't even
like
don't he was just like it deserves
no words just walk away and there's been
too much violence
i'd be mad but i'm still thinking about
that pizza sign across the street
the whole [ __ ] show i'm like god
pizza's brilliant food pizza
pizza is probably not the first thing i
should eat after i break a fast too it
feels a little gooey yeah a little bit
very bready and stuff yeah all right we
got questions
all right question number one ask of we
these questions three this is uh z
howard 1992
wants to know what fictional product you
would like to have sponsor
this show and what would your
advertisement be
so uh like the mattel hoverboard from
back to the future
would be an example oh um
the plumbus from rick and morty
uh the sponsor uh fat man beyond
sponsored by the plumbus
and what was the other part of the
question uh what would the ad
be oh um [ __ ] it
it's a plumbus
[Laughter]
nice thank you um
this episode of fat man beyond is
brought to you by the good folks at
recall
for the vacation of your dreams oh my
god i want to go to your world
right now could you imagine if we had
recall right now
no one would be engaged in 2020.
i'd be like take me back to 2019. i had
a great year
i just passed the one-year anniversary
of
um when we put our hands and feet print
into the cement at the chinese theater
which means me and jay which means that
it's also the one year anniversary
of when the movie went out on fathom so
it's the one year anniversary of reboot
coming out
october 19th which is a few days from
now is the one year anniversary of the
first
night of the tour in new jersey but
tomorrow mark
october 17th is the one
no the 25 year anniversary
of the mall rats premiere party which
means that
on october 20th it will be the legit
25th anniversary of maureen wow
i'm that [ __ ] weird man i saw i did
see that uh
the clark college piece from ew lovely
piece
yeah that was really he always whenever
i interview with clark
the first thing out of his mouth is
how's mark bernardin
because he's usually screaming over the
phone but he does he's like how's mark i
love mark i work with myself i know i
remember i always remember you remind me
every time every time i remember
he's the sweetest man great guy and he
did a lovely [ __ ] piece that was in
ew and stuff
for uh the arrow video released a 25th
anniversary mall rats
blu-ray which i spent last night going
through both discs and it was uh maybe
not last night the night before
and it was a real walk down memory lane
you know like maurice has never really
left my life
you know in any given year to the point
where i'm like i haven't [ __ ]
thought about my right i think about my
rats probably every day
but it's been a while since i watched
like
some of the extras and [ __ ] like that
and so they you know
some of the extras were on the 10th
anniversary dvd or whatever
but they had this like behind the scenes
interviews with the cast on the set
and you know i put up on twitter a
little peace of mind
everybody is so [ __ ]
earnest everybody's acting like we're
making argo
not mull rats it's very strange only
jason lee
has a smile like jason lee's the one
that's like
look i'm having a good time everyone
else is real serious of like
even me as the director i'm like it's
movie set in them two guys get broken up
with them so they go to a mall
i made clerks can't you tell like it's
so [ __ ] weird i just wanna grab that
kid and be like you make comedies you
make comedies you dick in any event
i had a good time other than that i had
a good time going through the dvd they
produced a stellar [ __ ] dvd there's a
wonderful
little jay only interview and that's
rare because usually i'm standing next
to him and so i got to see that
uh and then there was a nice piece they
did with dave klein which i really liked
over the phone you could tell because of
covid and stuff but they
put together with pictures and stuff
then they did this cool piece with like
people who worked on the movie in lesser
position not like rockstar positions
office pa
one of the extras the locations manager
and they animated it was really good man
so the whole thing's a wonderful package
and won that but yes
25th anniversary of mall rats comes up
october
20th that's awesome yeah so yes i would
like to recall
my way either 20 years ago 25 years ago
or i'd just go to 2019 that was much
better
yes or i would just like to get my ass
to mars because
maybe better than here yes get your ass
to mosque
dartmouth cohen give those people
all right man what a great question he
gets a prize or considered that the
divorce
um what's our next question jc
we had uh in chat somebody thought the
oasis from ready player one
would be a great sponsor for the show oh
and andrew
clever from the booth is texting me soul
glow
oh no
i couldn't hit that second i know sorry
andrew
yeah your fault andrew um
i also thought of like mr fusion oh [ __ ]
um weyland yutani building better worlds
and where's the uh what's the robocop
company oh omni
what is it omni consumer production
consumer product ocp
i buy that for a dollar all right what
do we got
sucks five thousand all right uh hank
pena
wants to know if you and mark can recast
avengers with sitcom characters
recasting avengers with sitcom
characters
okay who asked for this uh hank pena
hanks a million yeah where to go make
this work for this lesson yeah boy oh
boy
[ __ ] now we gotta think all right start
captain america
uh and his sitcoms from all of history
and [ __ ]
all all history sam malone perhaps
or and i'll probably be in the minority
on this one
james evans senior
[Applause]
america's dad i was gonna go tony danza
no what no he's got a good heart
yeah no not his cap no no
um i got real i got i got rules and
lines
and you just crossed one with that um
jim halpert from the office yeah
play captain america in america i buy
that but if you look at the camera the
whole time he's like
um okay iron man
uh jerry seinfeld what is the deal with
this iron
um i was going like steven
root in uh in news radio
just because he's rich just because he's
rich and jerry seinfeld is a real life
billionaire
well yeah but it's the characters not
the actors true
but i mean look i'm the biggest stephen
rude fan on the planet
but if you told me hey you know that
sitcom avengers has jimmy james as iron
man
i'd be like look i'm a fan but that's a
little much
it'd have to be it'd have to be some
huge sitcom
star so like seinfeld was huge who oh or
ray romano ah
[Music]
[Applause]
cap sign the accords
civil war with ray romano
[Laughter]
i don't think it'll get better than that
so perhaps we just leave that question
right there
[Laughter]
take us to question three take us home
jc
on the accords
what was his brother's name what's his
brother's name
what is it robert
get him to sign the accords all right
i think we're gonna get to frasier crane
is doctor strange oh my god well that's
[ __ ] great
that's fantastic dr fraser crane as dr
steven strange um
well we need before we leave it we need
one lady we need one
lucy as the scarlet witch or as black
widow as black widow
lucy as black widow
or mary kate olsen as
the scarlett
on fire i guess this is our last show
apparently this is [ __ ] jc's got all
the jokes the j
stands for jokes that's awesome
that's a great answer uh and then who
else is left thor
who's
[Laughter]
cousin larry i am god of thunder
i was going to go chris evans from parks
and rec as thor
but chris no what's his name chris
not evan's matt evans um what's his face
pratt
pratt that's thor wow how weird
a little bit you could have him be an
avenger even though
he wasn't even um and then hulk we need
a hulk
oh andrew [ __ ] wins the day
john goodman has the hulk no makeup
he's that good an actor um all right
that was fun welcome well done hank
hank's a million in the chat oh dear
herrera says alf as rocket raccoon
oh that's great
excellent pull wow man
all right let's get off of this because
i'm not feeling creative enough to beat
that
i i kind of want jeffrey from fresh
prince as jarvis
oh
just keeps getting better and better um
oh and you have to get will as uh
as james rhodes will smith as jim rhodes
as rhodey
um and as uh as
oh lucy as pepper lucille ball is pepper
potts
no lucille ball is the black widow oh
did we go
oh yeah pepper potts
marion cunningham from happy days is
pepper potts
see i was gonna go marry lou henner as
uh
as black widow yes but like in a world
look
she's my neighbor and i respect the hell
out of her but in a world between
lucille ball
the queen of the [ __ ] sitcom and
television and
mary lou henner who's got a very good
memory and was in taxi
i i think it's lucille ball
maybe mary lou henner could be the
scarlet witch red hair okay
what about there you go she's in and
she'll remember everything including
every spell she'll need to cast because
she got a photographic memory there you
go
okay we got this now do ultron
james evans senior james evans seniors
well vicky from small wonder is ultron
good call good call man we need a vision
as well
which also has to be a tv android or a
robot
could it be ham and yo-yo remember that
show one cop was a [ __ ] robot
oh [ __ ] oh that's not a sitcom i was
gonna be like data but that's yeah
i was gonna say kit but that's also not
a who what it has to be like other than
small wonder isn't there some robot
show some [ __ ] falls in love with a
robot
we're a robot butler are we just are we
spitballing the show right here
well is it starts as a robot butler but
she falls in love or
he it's [ __ ] rosie from the jetsons
oh and starring rosie from the jetsons
no not ultra on his vision she's a hero
oh vision right ultron is small wonder
girl which is actually a very brilliant
idea
um [ __ ] man erkobot is what chad is
saying urkelbot
from family matters it's pretty damn
great that is pretty damn great i think
although you could have saved urkel for
loki
did i do that i feel like
but urkel is [ __ ] as as ultron though
did i do that did i do that
i'm sorry um that was [ __ ] fun
alex p keaton is peter parker he's
in the chat i buy that i mean he's a
little old
but the high school he was presented as
a high school kid yeah no i guess
that works yeah
who's thanos
fox
it's the big one lizbeth they're coming
they're coming elizabeth i'm inevitable
elizabeth
um oh who's thanos duh mork from orc
thank you thank you archie bunker
oh that's better andrew wins again
archie bunker is [ __ ]
thanos and carol o'connor
as archie bunker as thanos
that's a great call all right third
question is going to get us out of here
and send you off
into your weekend send me home to
not eat furiously masturbate angrily
eat and then go to sleep early dreaming
of [ __ ] pizza
uh what do we got j.c okay last one uh
from angry pencil
studios um he or
she they are interested in
what are some of the coolest gifts you
guys have gotten from
fans and what are some of the strangest
gifts you have gotten from fans
one of the coolest gifts i ever got from
a fan look anytime somebody
renders me as a drawing or a sculpture
or something like that
that's amazing and i keep them they're
all around my house and stuff like that
but while i was on the j and zombob
reboot roadshow tour
um there were these two dudes who came
backstage afterwards like part of the
vip experience
and um they brought with them a
16 millimeter arie sr2
which is the exact same kind of camera
we shot clerks on
and the guy was like we clean out places
for a living
so like places that are like we were
cleaning out an old film school
and they had these cameras laying around
that were just
getting thrown out and i remember you
said something about an arie sr-2
so i thought you might like this and i
swear to you it was one of my favorite
things i've ever received
from a fan let alone anybody in my
entire life because i was like holy [ __ ]
it suddenly made me go like
why didn't i try to buy the real harry
sr2
that i [ __ ] made clerks on like
that's a goddamn treasure that was
literally the bridge to the rest of my
life
but in lieu of that i've got this area
sir too that now sits right in my office
i see it all the time so i love that
gift that was great
you um two things come to mind um
the first was it was somebody
who came to see the show here at scum
and villainy
he might have had one for both of us i
don't remember but
he was a guy who was kick-starting this
line of statues these gold-plated
statues
oh and uh and it was the notorious
m-o-d-o-k
yes and so it was like notorious b.i.g
it was notorious modok
so it was like big's face but he was
sitting on the modoc throwing with a
crazy motoc thing
and but it was all gold like the
infinity like the the fertility idol and
yeah and
the energy and uh and i still have that
at home because i thought it was the
coolest [ __ ] beautiful original piece
i got mine too and uh and the other
thing is
a guy who i i bumped into i want to say
i was at san diego
maybe it was new york i can't remember
which convention it was um
but he he you know long time listen to
the podcast
gave me a copy of black panther's first
appearance in fantastic four
like the book itself the original comic
the invisible
and it's worth money it's worth money it
was definitely at a convention because i
think he probably came
from one of the retailers who were at a
convention right he's like i saw this on
the wall and i had to get it because i
you know i know how much black panther
means to you and especially after you're
doing the
month of black panther shows and i feel
if anybody should have had it it's you
and i was like well dude i don't [ __ ]
know what to say he's like don't say
anything manchester
united's like just give me ten thousand
dollars again
it's yours that's a [ __ ] pricey book
yeah it's a nice gift
it's a really nice wonderful gift and so
like i i still have it like it's
it's on whatever version of a wall i
have in my house i don't know a bunch of
comic books up but it's
it's displayed in my house because it is
the most wonderful thing that
could not have been more unexpected but
also
more welcome and well deserved and well
well that's for other people to decide i
should
uh also include in that list uh a fan
once gave me a really nice piece of
artwork
and then i was like oh this guy's good
let's use him and he has done
every piece of artwork for fat man uh
on batman and fat man beyond and that's
our good old nate gonzalez who usually
sits
right there in front of us but
as we all know covet so he's not sitting
right there but
that was a fan who gave me something
where i was like
i i could use you and put him to work
and he's been working for us ever since
he got moxie kid let me exploit you for
money yeah i'm gonna buy your talent c
with money um yeah man so
it's fans give us great stuff the fans
i mean look without [ __ ] people
liking what i do i wouldn't even still
be here and [ __ ]
been doing this [ __ ] 26 years because
people are really nice man if you give
them something or say something that
makes a difference in their lives or
entertains them for a few moments
they tend to want to like pay you back
and they give you wonderful things and
they give you a piece of themselves they
make like
boxes they make artwork like i'm always
blown away when somebody gives me a
heavy piece of artwork cut from wood
featuring like me or one of my dopey
friends i'm like holy [ __ ] man that's
crazy so
thank you to all the fans who've ever
given us out of
anything uh me and this guy buddy
i would just like to say that i too
would like a first appearance of black
panther if anybody's
freaking out valuable comic books [ __ ]
if anybody's at a convention
whenever that happens just saying
looking for a near-mint copy though
that's my only caveat yeah i mean we're
going to go cgc we're going to slap you
if
you've got a poor copy you [ __ ] hold
on to that but you saved the near mints
for me yeah i'm not here for your
sentimental value
resale i don't want to read it i want to
price it and resell it
how dare you um that's it that's our
three questions
that's it although i'll share uh because
you guys
talking triggered my memory do it we had
a guy
uh come in here and um give us an
envelope and i get a lot of stuff here
also
star wars geeky patches and things like
that
this was a guy who worked at nasa on the
mars rover
and he had the opportunity to engrave
uh something on the mars rover that's on
mars
right now and he put the name scum and
villainy cantina
uh jc and jen are you [ __ ] me
so you got [ __ ] on them on mars we're
the first bar
on mars and that that choked us up like
that was the thing where we were oh my
god we're in space
for real ah that is [ __ ] beautiful
man
so that's something we'll never i mean
that's not your take with
guy he got his ass to mars oh my god how
[ __ ] awesome
um what a great note to go out on
seriously scum and villainy literally in
outer space
you could see scum and villainy uh
cantina on mars
you might not see it here anymore but
you can't see it on earth
if you join up with elon musk and you
get to mars you can join us there
there it is i mean you're franchising
clearly
second location first location hollywood
second location mars the
the martian surface the third location
the outer rim
third location poughkeepsie
people like why i like a cheap rent and
there was a guy who wanted to partner up
um there it is [ __ ] that's awesome it's
coming villainy in outer space that's
super cool
put a spring in my step made me slightly
less hungry
fill me with joy filled my stomach with
joy oh so now i'm not thinking about
eating
uh did you have a good time kids on
friday night i sure did
wouldn't be able to have that good time
unless we had some place to do it give
it up for
jc for letting us come into this here
borrow his coming villainy cantina
wouldn't have any
images to show your cameras to switch
around you wouldn't even know jc was
here
or not for andrew in the other room
flicking around cameras and stuff
still don't have a camera for himself
one day we'll put one back there so we
can go to the andrew cam
he'll be like the dude in the torpedo
bay who's just
huddled under giant wads of mechanics no
he's like uh
[ __ ] what's his name and uh in the
hunt for october where he's like
paganini
you know the dude who's like listen here
senior beaumont yes
cotton sonar crazy ivan crazy ivan
um all right and uh we really wouldn't
have a [ __ ] show
uh without the dudes standing in my left
give it up for mr martin
and that ladies and gentlemen we're not
having a show next week
um i don't believe we are unless another
news
a week of news breaks we got to get to
the fat cave
yeah and we have to get back here
emergency fed man our head
what are the what's the date today
today's the 16th
and so next week would be uh if it would
be the 23rd
so we may have a show maybe before i go
to
to uh or maybe we take that week off and
then have the show
november 2nd right before the election
then there'll be a lot of news
right i don't know we'll figure it out
we'll let you know yeah we'll be back
but in the meantime we're done now
this is finished we're going [ __ ] off it
is
done um maybe i'm gonna go have dinner
what should i have pizza
i'd rub it all over my nipples
can you send me a picture of that hand
you put me on the phone let me hear it
chicago style
speaking of chicago movies pop-up coming
to chicago go to moviespopup.com
um that's all we got for you man that's
the show for this week um
that's fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next time same fat time same
fat channel smilecast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith for the good of all cree
so say we all and uh wakanda forever
you